no one has any losses yet though it's
one of the beauties of this stage of the
calendar everyone's zero and zero and in
theory
everyone can continue to have zero
losses indefinitely that sparked a
comment over the weekend from patrick
mahomes the chiefs quarterback when when
pressed on the question of his
individual goals he said my only goal is
to go 20
and oh that became a thing because it's
kind of slow right now if you haven't
noticed andy reid the coach of the
chiefs and mahomes addressed
in sessions with reporters on thursday
the 20-0 comment from mahomes let's have
a listen
he was asked
you know what would
what would be a great challenge for him
and you know to to work for and so
you know 20-0 made sense but i mean it's
uh
he wasn't boasting about it that's not
what he was doing but he
he just said that's that would be a
great challenge which it would be i mean
we've got a
you know we've got a pretty stiff
schedule and uh some great competition
that we're going to play against so
um i felt like he was really saying
listen we all need to get busy and
and work our tail off uh because of so
what was your teammate's reaction when
when the news of that started going
around
i don't think there was really a
reaction at all i mean if you're in this
league you want to win every single time
you're on the football field
and i think people get a hype up about
saying 20-0 because you have to take it
one week at a time but at the end of the
day you you want to continue to win
every single week i'm not uh going into
the season hoping i lose any games on
the
goal of 20-0
obviously you're not the only
quarterback only team that wants to do
that there's 31 other teams that want to
do that but nobody else at least that
i've heard has gone public with it i'm
just curious why you decided you would
go public with that why you would come
out with that uh right now
yeah i mean i believe the the question i
was asked was what record that i would
want to break and
to me records don't mean anything if
you're not winning that last game at the
end of the season so uh
to me it's about going in every single
week with the mindset that we're trying
to win we're going to win
um and at the end of the day whatever
the record is if it's 20 and zero or
whatever it is you're winning that last
game of the season uh then you're gonna
be happy with whatever happened uh
earlier in the season
well that's for damn sure i mean
ultimately that's what you want to do is
win the super bowl but he did articulate
going 20-0 and look last season
the chargers game at the end of the year
they weren't trying to win patrick
holmes didn't play in that game and they
lost that when the only game they lost
other than super bowl 55 that they were
trying to win came against the raiders
and that was just kind of one of those
fluke things they they
they play down to the level of the
competition more than
than i would like to see but they still
find a way to win those games they can
find the gas pedal and it seems like
they inevitably do and i think that's
why the super bowl didn't seem like the
blowout that it was because we continued
to anticipate that they were going to
rattle off 24 points in a moment's
notice but you know peter of of all the
teams out there and i think points bet
has the odds at 40 to 1 for the chiefs
to go 17-0 in the regular season and for
the bucks it's 50 to 1. yeah look the
chiefs have as good a chance as any to
come out and rattle off win after win
after win because that's pretty much
what they've been doing the super bowl
may have clouded us a little bit this is
still a damn good football team and they
went out this offseason and they
addressed their weaknesses
you know no team
was
took one position group
i would say maybe other than new england
in the tight end position but no team
took one position group and improved it
the way the kansas city chiefs did with
their offensive line basically that was
the worst offensive line in the nfl on
super sunday the worst and they paid for
it with patrick mahomes getting
pressured and sacked and or sacked 29
times that is a phenomenally awful
performance by an offensive line
and what brett veach did obviously is
come out and when you add joe tooney
orlando brown
and very likely at some point you know a
solid rookie center in creed humphrey um
they have done a tremendous job
in rebuilding a very very weak part of
their team now about 20-0 here's the way
i look at it
you know
who who i it to me
who makes a big deal of this
because quite honestly
any quarterback right now is going to
say he wants to win every game if you
win every game that you play in the
course of a year you're gonna go 20-0 i
just to me it's the most ho-hum
uh bit of bravado i've ever heard a
player say what would you want a player
to say you know what our goal this year
is to go
and 17-3 but nobody's but he's the only
one who said it but he's the only one
who said it that's the thing no one else
is saying it even tom brady's not saying
it and and and even though tom brady is
not saying it i
he made the comment a couple weeks ago
he would trade two super bowl rings
for a 19-0 season now it would be 20-0.
i i think for him
that's one piece of unfinished business
that maybe he won't articulate
but that he would surely love to do yeah
he wants to get to number eight but if
he could get to number eight and not
lose a game along the way and they're
you know they're bringing back everybody
and that that it's just that that drive
from tom and tom internalizes a lot of
that stuff but yeah everybody wants to
win every game possible and this year it
gets harder because there's another game
to play
17. we've never had 17 regular season
games chances of anybody navigating
their own schedule successfully through
17 weeks and then through the postseason
very slim very slim i mean it hasn't
happened in 50 years so
the reason why it's going to happen all
of a sudden now
the reason why it's so slim mike is that
the vast majority i bet
at i mean maybe 32
but the vast majority of nfl coaches if
you have nothing to play for
in the last week or maybe even the last
two weeks of the season
they are going to take the foot off the
gas pedal
so it's just like you know
why would you think
that
andy reed would play
2021 any different than he played 2020.
you know if he doesn't have anything to
play for in week 17 or game 17 i should
say
he's going to take patrick mahomes and
some of his
guys out of harm's way in that game and
remember we got that lesson a couple of
years ago from the ravens who did that
and were flat against the titans in that
saturday night divisional round game and
maybe in hindsight they wish they had
played those guys and not given them
what amounts to three weeks off when you
throw in the buy on top of it but yeah
and with 17 games
we don't know how it's going to play out
but
you could have teams in theory
realize earlier
that you know that we've got three two
more than one game that's meaningless
because we've got everything sewn up
despite the number of games left but
that's a good point as well you have to
have a coach who's willing
to assume the risk of getting guys
injured in meaningless games to carry it
through and then when you do it if you
do go undefeated in the regular season
one thing rodney harrison has said in
the past and matt casey's reminded me of
it it put more pressure on them in the
postseason to put more pressure on them
in the super bowl to finish the job when
they were 18-0 and clearly that day the
patriots that we saw against the giants
were not the patriots that we had seen
all year long blowing people off the
field
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports